if you come with the expert and i'm the
expert when you're doing something no
one's ever done before
i don't want you on the team
because we all are learning about
something that has never been
in existence before and we have to bring
that level of vulnerability and openness
to new ideas and new ways of doing
things
throughout the team
so you want people that are
able to have like beginner's mind or
whatever like
don't don't come in as an expert what's
the story okay you're not allowed to
work okay no i can tell it's for sure
all right
so
so
you know you asked what were these risks
you know like on the early ipod and
there's there was there was a few big
risks like one and this this doesn't go
in the story but like putting rotating
media in your pocket and it could drop
at any time what happens there and like
you can damage because the heads and the
hard drive media are so close it smacks
it's dead right so that was one big one
like is holy [ __ ] right so that was
something we and we had to design
special tests and everything and special
software on that but then there was
another one which was at the early days
the way the first generations of ipods i
had to hack
the i had to hack the ide interface to
the hard drives
so i was like okay what we're going to
use is we're going to use this chip for
hard drive um
hard drive to make a hard drive you had
to have a chip that did firewire to a
hard drive okay and then that would
become a portable hard drive
well then that we had a uh um
we had the mp3 player and the user
interface and everything so there was
times when it was just this hard drive
and there was times when it was a mp3
player and i had to hot switch between
what the hard drive thinks it was
talking to yeah right so designed this
thing tore it apart done all this stuff
and i was like
you know maybe i'm going to screw up ide
and there's something there's some holes
i'm going to see
so i go who's the expert at apple who
understands ide and everything
so
this person comes over
the mass storage specialist comes over
and i put on the whiteboard and said
here's how we're going to do this thing
and here's the commands and this is how
it hot switches and everything he's like
that's never going to work yeah
i was like what it was never going to
work i said well let me go over here and
show you this right here i haven't
prototyped and it's been working for
days i just want to see if you're going
to have it find any holes in the thing
right didn't even get and he just
stormed out of the room and never never
even yeah right that's hilarious i've
had a lot of experience like this with
experts like for example this ridiculous
room
um i had uh
i had a person and
many people like this that
i i showed them here's the situation
you know it's acoustics or acoustics
yeah they're like no no no this is
horrible
this
does not this is not gonna work
the reflection
the the curtains are not gonna stop uh
the reflex there's a bunch of
terminology they're telling me um it's a
similar kind of situation as the idea
which i was like no i
listen
i just need to see is there major issues
and they're like a low-hanging fruit
that are fixable and major holes i
should be aware of not like that's 100
000 to upgrade to upgrade for what exact
purpose
what not why yeah exactly exactly the
why the focusing on the on the story and
the content on the the why the why do i
and that that actually i've experienced
that unfortunately in the artistic
realms too which is like
photography and videography
cinematography uh
it's interesting i talk to photographers
that are quote-unquote experts
and it's always about the so much of the
focus is on
the equipment
the equipment behind
the sensors and the lighting
and it's like all right
all right but um
what about
what about the feeling
of the story you create visually
the difference between a
a movie that's really well told
and it doesn't have all the effects and
everything versus maybe some of the
superhero movies we see all the time
which is good luck if there's a story
but man there's a lot of action and cgi
well that's that's right and that
and there's also value to the to to
those right cgi
superhero can tell a better story but
you have to have a good story to begin
with
sure exactly but it it's if you're
focused on the story i guess you need to
start with a story you need to start the
story and if you bring in experts
they can often be
detrimental
i guess to the why they're they're too
good at doing the what well you can
bring in experts for why
there's lots of experts for why
too many times we get experts for what
yes and then they only focus on the what
and so you so they come with the specs
and feeds and the the numbers and all
the other stuff but what you're really
asking for is i need somebody about the
why in understanding what we're trying
to get done here and fitting the what's
into that why
right that's why i i do think that
i i
one of the qualities that i really enjoy
for people to work with is like humility
for a particular problem when you
approach it
basically i don't know how to solve this
but we're going to figure it out as
opposed to oh i've solved this thing
many many times before i know exactly
what to do uh humility before the chaos
sort of having having an open mind that
this is going to require a totally new
way of doing
uh things it's a really nice quality to
see
you